how long do I have to be here you're
gonna be the most wanted man in the
world this is nothing to do with our
plan what's going on where's Lu we have
work to do hey guys Pete here gonna look
at the new footage from the upcoming
episode three of mr. robot season three
today there's also been some new photos
that were released and an interesting
tweet by the series creator Sam s mail
he was asked I was a count which episode
he was most excited for fans to see and
he said next week's episode is his
favorite so far
that's exciting he's done that in the
past when people have asked him and I
wasn't personally like down it happened
the last time I saw it happened was in
season two in the middle of the season I
guess and I remember thinking that he
didn't pull any punches he was telling
the truth and I don't think we'll be let
down as a result of that and on top of
that I think there's good reason to
believe that based on what we've seen in
this short promo it looks very much like
a flashback episode to a time we like
Elliot have been left in the dark about
bearded Tyrell and Irving seem to be
hiding out and the voice-over gives us
some pretty good hints about what's
happening at the same time the clips are
a bit hit or miss we don't see Angela or
Dom we don't see price we don't see
white rose except for one quick clip in
the promo photos we do see Angela though
and we'll talk about that after we get
through this trailer the complete
voice-over goes like this we hear Tyrell
say how long do I have to be here then
Irving says you're going to be the most
wanted man in the world Tyrell this has
nothing to do with our plan what's going
on where's Elliot we have work to do and
then we hear Tyrell say I will always be
loyal to Elle
real quick before we look at the images
the frame-by-frame I think it's
interesting that right before Joanna
died in Episode two she said that she
would always be loyal to Tyrell and here
we have him who's obviously hiding out
saying that he's always going to be
loyal to Elliott so the frame-by-frame
goes like this we see a big wide-open
shot from the top of a car driving I can
really make out his headlights it looks
like a car and it looks to be in a
wooded area that's all we can really
tell from that shot we see
regular-looking Tyrell entering a room
this is where he says how long do I have
to be here in the voiceover he's got his
regular clothes on here the stuff he
wears to evil Corp for his day job based
on what we've seen we have to imagine
this is the hideout and this is when he
first arrives there after the five nine
hack went down nighttime shot of New
York City comes next there is a little
Pontiac there that reminds me of the car
that was being driven by Irving in the
other episode the two guys I'm standing
behind it looked like they could be
Asian to me and then we see someone
coming up to them to talk to them my
guess on that one is it serving but
that's really just my best guess
see Tyrell in the house we have to
imagine it's the same house that he
entered and he looks stressed out by
what he sees on the computer screen can
a hundred percent make it out but it's a
pretty good guess that that's a article
about Joana and all the turmoil that's
caused obviously if he's in this house
is a safe house right after the hack
which I would guess that's what's going
on we have to imagine that this is where
he was through the entirety of season 2
so he's forced to watch all this stuff
go down and you remember how everything
was swirling around Joana
because they were trying to find him we
see him sharpening an axe which is
repeated several times through here he
seems to pick up a hobby of chopping
wood maybe it's like a chopping wood
therapy he goes and does to help
blow off steam while he's trapped in the
house we have this shot here that's
obviously later based on the beard he's
in disguised for the most part I don't
pick anything up in this frame to tell
me for sure where this is we do see a
little bubble camera there above the
doorway which makes it look like an
official location but there's nothing
else to tell us for sure where they are
right here
another shot of bearded Tyrrell sitting
in front of a terminal this is he's
looking back at someone this goes along
with the voice-over part where he says
this has nothing to do with our plan
what does that mean does that mean that
he has to do something else for them
while he's hidden away
is there another part of the plan he
didn't understand we really don't know
we don't know anything about those three
days really or for that matter what I've
been thinking about when I was looking
through this is we don't really know
what other interaction Tyrell and
Elliott had as far as planning's
concerned leading up to Tyrell being in
this safe house there's a shot here
where herbing looks pretty relaxed doing
crossword and we can see Tyrell through
the doorway there he's freaking out
looks like he has cabin fever at the
very least and Irving seems pretty
unaffected by the whole thing just shot
of Tyrell chopping wood from a higher
vantage point which is pretty cool
looking but I don't know what's going on
here see a map it has pins in it these
could be places where that they've seen
Tyrell or had sightings or something
along those lines you can see that some
of them have blackened heads and one has
red it's up in upstate New York
all in all they all seem to be around
that area could be one in Pennsylvania
or two in Pennsylvania there but they're
mostly around New York have a shot where
Tyros walking briskly through the woods
if not running with a backpack on does
he try to escape is he out to get
exercise you know we don't really know
he's just not in the house in this
particular part we see him again without
a beard this could be right when they
arrived this could be right before they
leave but the only thing that stands out
about this scene is that he's
clean-shaven then we see Eliot my best
guess of when this is would be after he
was shot he ended up in Angela's
apartment but at some point he had six
days that he doesn't remember see
another sequence of not bearded Tyrell
freaking out slamming his hands down on
a table see him cutting wood again still
doesn't have a beard in this scene get a
shot of white rose there seems to be
some guards there she's looking at a
tablet we see the kind of a flip of the
case but we don't know what else is
happening right there
here we have a exchange of a gun now
I've looked at this and the other part
this appears to be in the warehouse
where Elliot was shot so when I
initially looked at it I thought it was
probably her vein giving the gun back
after he cleaned up the scene but if you
look at the little bit of detail we have
there it almost looks like Elliot's hand
on the left hand side passing the gun so
I can't say for sure it looks like
somebody wearing a suit as opposed to
the mr. robot jacket on the right but I
can't say for sure got another shot of
the bearded Tyrrell with Irving there
just seemed to be lounging around
waiting which if you think about it they
probably did quite a lot of this since
they were hiding out it almost looks
like earthing could be nodding off here
like falling asleep for a nap this could
be related to Tyrell trying to run away
the very next scene we see him in the
woods again he's wearing his aviator
shades and he is startled by something a
shot of him in what looks like his
bedroom in the house he's closing his
laptop and someone standing behind him
that we're just gonna have to guess is
Irving because you can't see for sure
it's the only person that really makes
sense and there's really not much more
detail here to go off of we do see him
in bed he looks like he's having a hard
time sleeping then we cut to this car
and this seems to be the most loaded
sequence in the entire trailer you can
see that there's a vibe
in this car like a cop car which we see
later Tyrell was obviously frightened
about who's coming to the door it cuts
to Leon who's wearing an orange jumpsuit
so we're you have to imagine that this
is when Elliott was in jail but we can't
know that for sure this could be when
the dark army makes their approach for
him this next shot is pretty interesting
we see the SUV which we're gonna see
from the outside later and we see
Santiago looking in the car this is
where Tyrell was and it looks like Tyra
probably got himself picked up but
somehow Santiago comes along to spring
him now there's been a lot of clues that
give us the idea that Santiago is
probably working with the dark army I
brought that up in several videos and
this would seem to be confirmation of
that fact we saw an episode to the Dom
definitely doesn't know where Tyrell is
and if Santiago is right here with him
during that time when he was missing
that's pretty much a smoking gun that he
is helping the dark army and helping
Tyrell not be caught quick shot of
Darlene who's wearing her heart-shaped
sunglasses this makes me think that it's
probably a flashback to the season 1
timeline again but I can't tell you for
sure this is the shot that we've seen in
the first trailer with Tyrell and his
beard and Irving this looks less like
the house but we can't really say for
sure this could be Tyrells return to New
York here's the police car and the SUV
looks like a County police you can't
really make out the markings or anything
but it's definitely related to that
scene with Santiago and Tyrell in the
back we see the cuffs here those are
Tyrells hands and this goes in line with
him saying I'll always be loyal to
Elliott see him cutting wood one last
time get a quick sequence of shots
these are his aviators he looks like he
just got his new sunglasses interesting
sequence of mr. robot he has the gun in
his
and here he seems to be handing it to
someone who and this shot looks like
it's Elliott based on the sleeves it
looks like the hoodie where that splint
on the thumb came from and how mr. robot
ends up handing the gun to Elliott isn't
it clear by any stretch of the
imagination it brings up the idea we did
see that shot of the popcorn machine in
the trailer that we haven't seen yet
where we saw what looked like Elliott
punching out the glass but we're gonna
have to wait and see what's actually
going on here get a shot of Tyrells baby
on a baby can have to imagine this is
him watching from afar see a couple of
shots of a tea kettle boiling on a stove
that are cut with a shot of what we
imagine is Tyrells desktop you can see
the baby cam in one of the windows his
abs don't really give away a lot we see
this we see the unlimited power supply
batteries thing that he was talking
about overheating to blow up that
building or burn that building down we
see what looks like a PDF file of the
ventilation let me get these two guys in
the dark army mass was what we've seen
in the trailer this could be the house
the hideout I mean that's the most
likely idea when I first saw this I had
no idea where it would be at but when we
see Tyrol first walk in it looks like
there is some wood paneling in that
house we have this shot of someone
looking out of the curtains when what
looks like New York City
it looks like Tyrell based on the
clothes but it's not very clear but this
could be related to after he shaves his
beard and puts on the suit that we saw
in that other scene another quick look
at the tea kettle boiling and then we
get the back-and-forth of Elliott in bed
and mr. robot in bed and I would imagine
that that's a hint that when he got shot
they did sort of separate and that's how
mr. robots able to deal with Angela
without Elliot knowing up until this
point now those are probably in her
place when he's getting better actually
not in a hospital so that could give us
some information on how that
relationship got kicked off as far as
these photos that were released we
a couple of Angela one with her looking
up and one with her looking down in the
same location can't say for sure she
looks like she's dressed for work this
could be in her apartment this could be
when she first meets mr. robot we have
three shots of Irving and one he's in a
car and another he's walking out of that
building that we saw him coming out of
with Tyrell in the beginning of the
trailer and then we have one where he's
in a what looks like a lobby there's
some art there and a nice lamp it looks
like a lobby of a building but other
than the painting and the lamp I mean
there's really nothing to tell us where
that it's something that we've seen
before in this series that I can think
of and then we have one shot a Tyrell
that looks like it is in the building
where they worked on stage two so that's
pretty much it for new material like I
said the Sam s Mel Twitter post is
exciting it would be a really nice
payoff if we learn a lot about what
happened in those those days that were
in between the time that Elliott doesn't
remember and then also the time after
that up until Tyrell came back and
that's what it looks like we're gonna
deal with here I really wouldn't mind
that if the whole episode wasn't a
flashback except for a couple of things
here and there I mean obviously if
Angela Angela could be a flashback to we
don't really know but one thing I wanted
to point out was based on other trailers
and other shots we have of Irving we did
see him at Coney Island with those two
guys with dark army masks so the two
that are sitting on the couch in that
shot are probably those same two so
let's hope that we do see Coney Island
here there's nothing to say for sure we
will but that is some circumstantial
evidence that we might be tying in to
that the leon thing is a little bit out
of place i saw earlier this week that
someone pointed out that in the trailer
where we see leon he's actually in
Elliott's apartment we can tell because
of the lamp that's there he put a new
lamp in and there's a shot of Leon where
he's smoking in the one trailer and he's
sitting right next to that lamp does
that mean that he knocked off Mobley and
Trenton I mean I I still kind of doubt
that because I just don't see they were
such a big part I just don't see them
not have
and ending in the show but that's
possible it's also possible he might
have brought them back but we don't know
we're in this season's timeline that
fits in I think with him in jail that
you know it's most likely that they have
him we find out how he ended up
protecting Eliot and if you didn't read
the book in the offseason you know we
learned a lot more about that time but
we really don't learn that much more
about Leon other than what he did to
help keep Eliot safe so I'm really
excited this season's been going great
check out my recap for episode two if
you haven't seen it yet I'll be doing
one more video this week before the new
episode comes out hopefully tomorrow
I'll take a look at all the Easter eggs
because there was a whole lot of them
that popped up it'll be a things you
might have missed video for episode 2
and that'll be coming next please like
the video if you enjoyed it make sure
you subscribe to my channel if you're
into mr. robot I plan on keeping up with
everything throughout the season and I
need your support to keep on doing that
so subscribe to the channel and turn on
notifications so you'll know when my
next mr. robot video comes out follow me
on Twitter or Instagram or Facebook so
we can keep in touch over there and
thanks for watching guys I'll talk to
you soon